Hello?
If what I saw was true,
there's nothing to stand
between this world
and utter destruction.
It's up to us
to save this place.
who lives
and who dies?
Think the hard choice.
You better
walk away.
Come on.
You're the God of mischief.
Always have been and always will be.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Marvel
just released another Loki
Season 2
trailer is part of a special integration
they're doing with McDonald's
during the series and also in real life.
now, a lot of people are getting strong
Rick and Morty vibes like,
oh no, they're not doing the special sauce
Rick and Morty thing again.
Hopefully Crazy Stans will come
out of the woodwork and start going nuts.
we also learned what's going on
with the characters, the Larger Kangs,
the Council of Kangs and Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty and Secret War.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'll be doing episode videos
just like I did during season one.
It'll start
right after the Asoka episodes,
which are starting in a couple of weeks.
I'll do videos for all those episodes too,
so no worries.
but in the new trailer footage and scenes,
we see Loki discovering where
Sylvie has been hiding in the timeline
since the end of season one.
All I can think of
when I see her at McDonald's here
is that funny family guy meme.
more to like than that. But by weight.
Ding, would you like an apple pie
with that getting fries and king fries?
I don't make
you can make all the jokes you want
about Loki wanting that quote
unquote sweet apple pie.
the fact that Loki fell in love
with another version of himself
is the most Loki thing
that he could possibly have done.
that's how vain he is.
He loves himself the most.
just explained what happened to her
at the end of season one
because we only saw that tag scene of Loki
arriving back at the TVA to the changed
timeline, where everything was
just a little bit different
at the end of season one, Sylvie
pushed Loki back to the TVA, using he
who remained Kang's portal device
that he given to them
earlier in the episode,
like he just offered it to them.
he either wanted them to kill him
or replace him.
He didn't care which the reason
why is just out of extreme boredom.
He lived as literally the name implies,
the last remaining
human living in the multiverse
for millions of years.
At this point, when they're meeting him.
so at a certain point had reused a life of
to collapse all the multiverse down
to the sacred timeline, defeating
the Council of Kangs in the first version
of the timeline, he just grew bored
like time just marched on.
He just eventually stopped caring as much
they called it, sort of like a gray
gardens Willy Wonka kind of situation,
because in Willy Wonka, he's trying
to find a replacement for his factory.
inside his citadel at the end of time.
Remember one of the statues of
those people was broken
That was meant
to be the statue of the kang
that they banished to the quantum realm.
I'll talk
more about him at the end of the video
because I think he's connected more
to what's happening in Secret Wars,
which is like beyond Avengers five.
But once he'll be killed.
He remains the locks that he put in place,
keeping his sacred timeline
from branching out in the true multiverse,
with his variants
all rising in alternate timelines and
universes stops the timeline does reboot
all possible timelines begin to branch out
at will into alternate universes.
Council of Kangs rises again.
We saw them in the Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantumania Post-Credits scene
once that started to happen.
In the immediate moments after he died,
Sylvie took his portal device,
jumped back to the 1970s
somewhere in the UK.
Not sure exactly where she's at in here,
but she's somewhere in the UK.
stars hiding out
from the new version of the TVA
by pretending to be a totally normal,
boring worker at a random McDonald's
like hiding out by being
the most ordinary, uninteresting person
she could possibly be.
This is too much.
I don't want to deal with this anymore.
I'm just going to go live this boring life
pretending to be a normal McDonald's
worker.
fries it ten king fries
Damn Notice
her uniform has all those gold bars.
When Loki finds her, meaning
that she'd been an upstanding employee
for a good long
while, Lacy's settled into this totally
ordinary, vanilla, uninteresting,
uncomplicated, boring life.
Loki, on the other hand, as we saw in
the trailers,
has to do kind of a speedrun version
of the beginning of season one again,
because none of the TBC agents like Mobius
remember him.
Only he Sylvie all the Kang
variants in Renslayer.
Remember the events of season one
so he has to re-explain everything
that happened
at the beginning of season one. that's
why you see him back in the prisoner
jumpsuit being interrogated by Mobius.
he starts slipping
through his own timeline uncontrollably.
Kind of like glitching in Spider-Man
across the spider-verse,
but a little bit different in that he's
jumping around in his own timeline.
He's not glitching just because
he's in the wrong universe or anything.
it looks like they go get Kahui
Quan's help.
Who's the head guy of the TBA?
His name is Ora Burrows,
which literally means time eater.
they discover that time itself is broken
and unraveling like a rope.
And that's probably why things are going
crazy all over the place.
boot, there is no actual kang
ruling over the TV.
Ah, inside the TV's a big mystery
about what happened to him
because we saw the statue
at the end of season one.
early theory.
That's probably
because something happened
to this variant of Kang
that's now running the TV
at the start of the TVA
because of the new version of the Kang
multiverse War, which has already broken
out in the wider multiverse.
while they're trying to fix that
and figure out
what's going on
with all the different Kang
variants, Loki is able to track down
Sylvie at that 1970s McDonald's.
They also traveled to the 1970s
on a regular TBS mission to stop
a nexus event
being caused by the zany character.
he's totally crazy in the comics.
I explained him
in my previous trailer video.
He is a super meta comic book character,
which is a bit of a play on the fake
in universe movies
like the Wonder Man movies that are made
They're actually doing a real life
Marvel Wonder Man series.
the series will follow him in his alias
as he pretends to be this Hollywood actor
making all these fake in universe movies
that you see them advertising in different
real life Marvel movies,
they might learn about Sylvie
when they're back in the 1970s
taking care of Zaniac just because she's
in that same time period.
Also in the UK, at some point
Loki's able to win her back.
They return to the TVA where you see them
arguing of a greater problems
they face inside this automat.
when so the argues with him about playing
God and he says that they are remember
they're both Loki's
from different universes.
And Loki is supposed to be the Norse
god of mischief.
So technically he's not wrong.
They are supposed to be gods.
But Loki isn't a god
the same way that Thor is a God.
Like he's
not literally a God in the cosmic sense.
The way that Thor was born, a God to Odin
who was a God himself.
Loki is more like a highly evolved being.
Like the Frost Giants
do have their own gods that they worship,
so they themselves are not gods.
this is why
Thor is fundamentally different
from the regular Asgardians like Valkyrie.
Valkyrie just like a really strong
Asgardian Thor is an actual God.
their actual argument,
though, is about which nexus events do
they stop, which people do they prune
if they're now in control of the TVA,
trying to fix the timelines
so it's paying off that he remains
seen from the end of season one even more.
he wanted them to take his place
running the chocolate shop,
so to speak,
Willy Wonka style running the TVA.
They kind of wind up doing that.
Even if they don't want to.
while that's going
on, you have the Council of Kangs
running wild, doing anything
and everything that they want,
messing
with the multiverse in the background
one of the missions
Loki takes them on to find a Kang
variant is to the 1890s at this World's
Fair to stop Victor Timely Kang
I think this is supposed to be the Chicago
World's Fair from the late 1800s.
think of any sort of
like the Nikola Tesla version of Kang
because that's kind of the vibe
they're going with here.
that's also why his Mist menace
that he created looks old timey
because he himself is pretending
to be old timey separately.
You also have Ren Slayer, who's back.
It's the same Ren slayer that escaped
through the end of season one.
It seems like she was warned by
he who remains Kang
what was going to happen
and how to survive.
She's Kang's love interest in the comics,
but in the comics she's just a love
interest of the main version of Kang.
it's unclear
if she's going to have a relationship
or become a love interest
for one of these new Kang variants.
At some point, supposedly
they're going to feature a number
of different Kang variants
during the season, not just Victor Timely.
I don't think
they made a whole lot of changes
because of all the Jonathan Majors stuff
that's going on.
If they've changed anything
is to like the very end of the series
in the way they wrap up his story arc.
we probably won't learn about that until
the actual final episode winds up airing
early theory
is that the Post-Credits scene
will probably be something
connected to Loki.
Season three in Avengers five Qin Dynasty.
Just because so much of
this is tied to the Kang plot,
assuming they do a season three,
they probably release it either
right before Avengers
five or they could always do it
between Avengers five and Avengers six.
A lot of
you've been asking about this too.
Will they do series set on Battle World
if they're between Avengers movies
the idea is that at the end of Avengers
five, a different,
more powerful version of Kang
will resurface and kill.
The Council of Kangs
collapsed the multiverse into
a single world for the entire of reality
which is a few of the heroes
from different universes left.
And they try to stop him.
but if there's going to be a whole year
between Avengers movies
when they've collapsed the multiverse
that One World Will series
be set on that world
if they're released between movies
they also made right up splitting
secret Wars into two different movies
which would make that problem even worse.
Like you'd have to have some of the
theories centered on battle world.
Right.
Now, the report is that they want Doctor
Strange three to be the final Marvel movie
right before Avengers five.
Because Doctor Strange
is supposed to be so important
for Avengers five and Avengers six.
But before all of these changes happened,
reportedly
the way they were going to plot it out
is that during Avengers five
you have the new version of the MCU
Avengers that assemble
to fight the Council of Kangs,
the dynasty of Kangs.
That's why the movie is called Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty.
they wound up getting their asses
handed to them like they aren't
powerful enough to defeat the Council
of Kangs, but they pay off the scene
from the end of Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania.
Maybe with that version of Kang surviving,
resurfacing
in, paying off his quote, talking to me
about how he wanted revenge
against the Council of Kangs
in his first act
would have been to kill them.
So the idea is that the Avengers
aren't powerful enough to kill Kang.
Only another kang can kill the Kangs.
whoever that kang winds up being.
He's the person that then collapses
the rest of reality
to the single battle world.
And you have the events of secret wars
we'll start getting more Loki Season
two trailers while Ahsoka is happening.
So be sure to enable alerts
from our channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
click here for that other big Loki Season
two trailer video and click here
for my new Asoka trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!